i want to bring something up that's kind
of crazy 15 years right is this right
the 15th anniversary of high school
musical
[Music]
what do you remember from that those 15
years ago when you're first on that set
it's so weird to me that it's that long
ago because
i feel like when i go to work and when i
especially get to do a musical i still
feel the same excitement and and joy
and passion for it as i did then
i feel like my job it turns me into a
big kid or i get to be a big kid because
i'm playing pretend i mean i'm now on my
little pony so you know like the child
like wonder of it all it never dies and
i'm i'm still so humbled and so grateful
for
all the opportunities and all the
adventures i've had
what the
ah
hi new friend unicorn
this is your first animated project i am
the father of a six-year-old i've
watched it twice it's awesome it's fun
how was it getting out of the hair
makeup trailer out of the seat for a
second and just using your voice for
this thing oh it was so nice it was so
nice i i'm i'm a cozy broad so like i
love showing up to work and being able
to stay cozy all day and really just
digging into this character and the
story and you know it's such a great
story it's such a great character i just
loved every minute of it i was so
excited i think they were kind of like
taken aback by how excited i was what do
you hope the audience takes away from
this movie there's so many things i mean
finding your sparkle celebrating
your universe and your individuality i
think is is such an important message
especially for kids and as well as
inclusiveness you know i you meet these
characters and they had never met the
different breeds before and they were
told that they were dangerous and sunny
doesn't subscribe to that message and
she's like no there once was a time when
their they were all friends and through
an adventure she becomes friends with
these different breeds of ponies and
magic happens and i feel like while we
might not have things floating around
with our friendship and the magic that
it creates there is there is a true
magic within friendship and it's one
that should always be celebrated yes and
finding your sparkle is the most
important thing ever
how are you most like sunny your
character oh there's a lot of ways we're
both a little cokey at times we both
stand up for what we believe in we're
both go-getters that is for sure um
and we're both very down for an
adventure now she roller skates do you
have a hobby that has helped you over
these last you know let's call it two
years now have you had a hobby you've
leaned on or anything multiple hobbies
i've definitely leaned into multiple
things at one point i got a poll and i
was like taking zoom lessons pole
dancing um which was
tough i had a lot of bruises but i
that's no joke i hear it's a hell of a
workout it's a tough workout yeah eating
i did a lot of beading i made a lot of
anklets and necklaces and bracelets
definitely leaned into some art
did a bit of like painting and coloring
a lot of music and a lot of movies and
tv i want to ask you have some serious
hashtag couple goals going on with cole
what makes him so perfect why you guys
look so happy all the time we're just
like the same we're very similar we're
very similar we're such weirdos it's
wonderful
[Music]